joining me now here in studio in dc the
dc bureau at fox news is brett baer
chief political anchor for fox news
anchor of course of special report every
week night at six eastern host of the
hit podcast brett bear's all-star panel
also a best-selling author most recently
of to rescue the republic you can follow
him on social as i do at brett baer
great to see you brad thanks for having
me of course to rescue the republic by
the way
is a wonderful christmas gift
i'm glad you mentioned that brad
how can people find that fantastic book
for their loved ones at this yuletide
season yes that's right i think amazon
probably is easiest but um bretbair.com
you can go the link right there and uh
it is a great thing for history buffs
and so i'm trying to compete with all of
these other fox books exactly you can go
and buy like a companion package where
you get the serious stuff with brad on
ulysses s grant and then you can go get
all-american christmas from the duffy's
right which i'm in you're in right you
have a story in there i do the christmas
uh the bear christmas tradition which
i'm going to ask you about actually
coming up in a few minutes okay but
first let's talk hardcore politics it's
what you do every single day yes we're
here in dc
i saw you tweeted just a little while
ago you had a little not a run-in but an
encounter with bernie sanders i did it
was hilarious it was perfectly on brand
for him what happened so i was up there
uh we're voting on uh the senate radio
tv
the next head of uh of that and
jared halpern yeah and so i went over
there walked over the senate gallery and
while i'm walking by the senate chamber
uh are senator sanders and i said
senator sanders good to see you he said
brett good to see you
and i said so what's going on over here
today he's like exactly what is going on
over here today and i said so are you
frustrated he said brett i'm always
frustrated
it's the truest thing he's ever said
yeah that was a brief encounter i
thought i'd just uh document it but uh
listen from a progressive point of view
progressives are frustrated they're
pulling their hair out
in on capitol hill because
this was their nightmare this is stalled
just like
a lot of them predicted it would and
they bought in to voting on the
infrastructure bill
it passed
and that's let's take that as a success
for the biot administration although
they don't really get all of the success
from it legislatively because they tied
this other bill to it and then they
promised the progressives that we're
going to get this through well it's not
getting through and i don't think joe
manchin is the only cog in the wheel i
think there are other moderate democrats
both in the house and the senate who
have real problems in the face of rising
inflation yeah there's a lot right there
to unpack because i think it's true on
multiple levels
joe manchin and this is the dynamic that
i think a lot of people and sort of the
activists in the twitter class
miss joe manchin is happy to be you know
the the lightning rod out front
strike me every day call me a right wing
whatever it helps me back home in west
virginia the polls in west virginia he's
doing great
buildback better is very unpopular in
west virginia he's like this all
benefits me in the meantime he's like
giving some some cover to other
members of his party who don't want any
part of this but they don't want to say
it out loud right now and he
because it's a 50 50 he can take the
slings and arrows it kind of works out
okay right and yes of course maggie
hassan in new jer in new hampshire
mark kelly who's up for election in
arizona
they don't want to vote on something
that is not popular in the face of
rising inflation i mean they can talk
about the good things in the bill
all day long but when you put it all in
there and you start to add up how much
it costs over 10 years not two or three
suddenly you're looking at a five or six
trillion dollar bill and we just put 1.9
and then two trillion dollars in the
economy so part of my analysis yesterday
my opening monologue because all this
was sort of falling apart yesterday for
real right and they were starting to
almost admit that it was falling apart
as opposed to continuing the fiction and
trying to make it work behind the scenes
i thought
not first of the progressives i got to
them eventually but i was thinking the
house
moderates quote unquote the vulnerables
every single one of them except for one
voted for this thing in the house it has
tax increases for the middle class it
has tax breaks for millionaires
they are saddled with that vote and what
do they have to show for it the good
stuff isn't gonna happen if it doesn't
become law so they marched with pelosi
off the
gangplank voted for this thing they've
got nothing to show for it i would
imagine there's probably some
frustration not just on the bernie wing
but on the people saying what on earth
do we do this for right yes a hundred
percent and you know they're aiming the
frustration at mansion um but manchin is
saying listen i told you time and time
again
my number was 1.75
you get under it you figure out how to
get under it but don't give me the
gimmicks don't give me the things going
to expire next it was very transparent
up front he gave schumer a letter which
essentially said here's the ingredients
that i need to make this
you know stew and um they didn't do it
then you've got the progressives and i
mentioned it just a moment ago just a
little interjection this was their
nightmare the reason that they held the
bipartisan infrastructure bill hostage
for was it months was because they were
worried and they said this it's not like
we're playing parlor games and we're
speculating they said it over and over
again publicly we worry that if we do
the moderate bill that republicans have
bought into at least dozens of them they
can go take all that credit and then
mansion and cinema say look we did
something
and then they say no thank you to all
this other spending that we really care
about
and leadership had to figure out a way
to say no no we're going to make it all
happen so then they lined up and did the
voting thing and then exactly the
concern is what's playing out right now
that's why you've got bernie
extra frustrating
today he was he definitely was and um
did pelosi sort of blow this because in
some ways she got the votes that she
needed out of the house but she's now
exposed all of her vulnerable member
members on these issues and the
progressives are going to be pissed off
something awful moving forward so she
got a win as the self-proclaimed master
legislator but is this really a win
i don't think so it's and i don't think
it's going to turn out to be
a win i think who really screwed it up
was chuck schumer repeatedly saying that
they're going to do a vote before
christmas
and then suddenly you're not going to do
a vote before christmas and you're going
to do
some appointments and ambassadors and
judges
and you're not going to do voting rights
either because you don't have the votes
either right so which is going to make
them mad again again so
you know after the first of the year
could they restart and scale back and
get under the 1.75 yes 100 percent they
could but then on the house side
again i've talked about this it's
legislative jenga you pull out a piece
and the thing starts tilting and you
lose the progressives and suddenly you
can't pass it although
here's the one devil's advocate that
i'll play here on that let's say mansion
says here's what i'll do
we'll do the child tax credit and that's
it or like one or two other things build
back better as it exists is gone but
we'll do something right and then
schumer says oh gosh are we going to do
nothing let's try that so let's say they
pass that out of the senate goes over
the house
i could imagine aoc and that whole crew
losing their mind saying this is totally
not what we agreed to
but have we seen the progressives
actually stand their ground and tank
something never so
ultimately i think that they whine and
scream and complain if they get
something that in their mind is woefully
inadequate i think they whine and scream
and complain and then vote yes that's
that's my theory on them until they
prove otherwise i agree because their
bark is loud their bite so far is
zero
you just have to sell it you know you
have to get the votes and it's always
always about the votes
so and there's no guarantee of that in
either chamber exactly
exactly and i think you know manchin is
is
going to want to show his caucus that he
can work on some things
and so it keeps on saying he wants the
child tax credit and that could be one
of them but in order for him to vote yes
it has to get under that magic number
for him
let's turn inward for a moment and we
can perhaps the audience can indulge us
but i want to bring this to their
attention
here at fox news we have closed out 2021
as the most watched cable network not
cable news network cable network on all
of cable for the sixth consecutive year
that is
mind-blowing i know we've just
celebrated 25 years at fox it's been a
privilege for me to officially work here
since 2013 although i was an intern for
a couple years before that you've been
here longer than i have brett we talked
about it during the celebration of the
anniversary
as the signature political anchor of
this network
we've been through a lot the last couple
years it's been a bumpy ride it
continues this week it actually seemed
like a year you know it did now that you
mention it but let's keep going we can
we can move on from that uh but it's
been a bumpy ride from time to time and
yet
when the chips are down our viewers keep
coming back and back and back to watch
fox news for their coverage political
and otherwise it means so much to me
being a small part of it you're a bigger
part of the success i just wonder what
your reflection is because
you never want to take it for granted
because
it's not automatic it takes that earning
that loyalty every single day 100 and
we're trying to do that every day and uh
it is great the viewers are very loyal
and you know i travel the country and if
somebody sees me and you know says hello
and says i want you all the time uh
somebody i'll be with says wow do you
get tired of of that happening and i say
no because exactly the same way if they
stop doing that that's a problem we
don't have a job yeah so they've never
stopped doing it and i've been here
almost 25 years
and uh it's really it's been
quite a ride and i think
as we get into this next year it's going
to be crucial that people get
balanced coverage and they're not seeing
it at other places
you can't go to other places for
coverage where you come to an end of an
hour and say i get to decide what i
think about that now we have opinion
shows that obviously do what they do but
we have new shows that
really provide that ability and i think
it's going to be really really key in
2020 and it does seem like our
competition
in many cases they spend a lot of their
time and energy
watching and talking about and covering
us it's amazing
it's really amazing it's like do we get
we should get some credit for those
ratings right because the amount of time
they spend talking about us so can we
like get a little cut out of that i know
it seems like we could talk to nielsen
about that i never want to be the news i
want to cover the news
which is what you do every week night 6
pm eastern on special report okay so
last topic
far less serious and we teased it
earlier with the duffy's book
all-american christmas you made a cameo
as you mentioned in there
bret bear and bear family christmas
traditions i know one of your traditions
and i've never actually read this book i
have not yet okay i've read bits and
pieces
i read some of uh steve ducey for
example he had a very fun story um and
we had actually we're going to have the
duffy's on our christmas special here at
the guy benson show talking about this
one of your traditions that i have never
yet witnessed is the special report
christmas party where you rap yes and i
know i've seen it on video but that
could be a deep fake right i need to see
it in person one of these years i know
unfortunately this year we we decided
because of the environment understood
that maybe the the bar and the band as
long as you didn't have one and didn't
tell me as long as you didn't do that no
you're invited 100
and um and we'll do it again next year
we will definitely do that but in your
household in the household yeah what do
you guys do are there certain things
that you've done all the way back to
when you were just a little baby brett
or do you have some new traditions as a
father and as a husband how do you guys
do christmas well you know it evolves as
your kids get older and uh it changes
dramatically actually and uh but in the
young years
the uh santa traditions were
unbelievable and my family traveled uh
growing up and we went to my mom was a
uh a travel agent so we went to san juan
puerto rico every christmas it was a
tradition oh wow and uh so
i was singing you know spanish feliz
navidad navidad and i was at a chichi
rodriguez golf course and my best golf
present was chichi rodriguez golf clubs
when i was like seven or eight years old
so uh that became the golf has been a
long-standing passion it has okay it has
um
but i think that uh
the biggest tradition is that you know
we spent we go to church
uh usually midnight mass and i was an
altar boy for many years and there's a
thing that sounds about right in the
book where um
where i was an altar boy and i was going
down the
the front of the church and there's a
big procession and they had hoods on
which i don't recommend and how it looks
but there were hoods on and it was just
supposed to be this
ceremonial thing and i put the candle
too close to the hood
and so the smoke got into the hood and
said altar boy went down
face first and all i remember is waking
up and the priest saying are you okay
and the entire midnight mass looking
this ground to a halt yes because brett
was face
but you were covered thank you i did fun
alter bore stories that's what you have
to look forward to and no that's just
one of the things
question about gifts we have a few
minutes left to me i've gotten less and
less excited about receiving gifts as
i've gotten older i like giving them i
like experiences i like being with
family and that sort of thing but an
actual you know like opening presence
and stuff it's not something that gets
me giddy of course like you know used to
when i was a kid although i have to say
i just heard about a christmas gift it's
the most excited i've been about in
years my father-in-law is a kansas grad
and he said we've got friends they're
big donors they've got tickets
i want to bring you guys for a weekend
to come see ku basketball and allen
fieldhouse i am
so stoked on this that's great i found
this out hours ago and i've been like
planning it ever since
what is the most excited you have ever
been for a christmas gift
that's a great great question i am most
excited this year because we've decided
to not do things but to do experiences
to your point
so each of us is going to come up with
an experience in my family that we're
all going to do together as a family
i love that and obviously i would ask
you what they are but no spoilers no
spoilers we'll have to have you back
and i know they listen then that's amy
every day
she loves the podcast many people are
saying many people are saying that's
what people say
brett baier chief political anchor at
fox news anchor of special report see
him at 6 p.m on fox news channel pick up
to rescue the republic for the uh
history buff and fox's fan in your life
you can follow him on twitter and
instagram at brett baer merry christmas
brett great to see you you too we'll be
right back